welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee I am councilor Mary
McLaren and I'm chairing the meeting
today may I first remind you of some
domestic
Arrangements if you're attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please ensure your mobile
phones and laptops are un
silent additionally we will be using EV
voting this meeting on the.gov
app the council members of the public
and the Press May record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded if you are intending to do so
please inform the committee
clerk if you hear the fire alarm leave
the building immediately via a fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
which is z switch football
ground follow the signs directing you to
the fire exits at each end of the
floor do not enter the atrium which is
the ground floor area and walkways if
you are in the atrium at the time of the
alarm follow the signs to the nearest
fire exit use the stairs not the lifts
do not reenter the building until until
told it is safe to do
so
we have at this meeting the following
people in
attendance councelor John Ward Cabinet
member for finance assets and
Investments Arthur chono our chief
executive Karen wlin interim corporate
manager for finance commissioning and
procurement Sean Coulter senior Finance
business part partner Jenny Smith's
Finance business partner we have Mark
uh director for
operations uh and we see we've got
um Tom Barker as well director for
planning
and are you covering
for are you coming through anybody
Tom just here to support the finance
team as one of the directors thank you
so uh s b is here to support the finance
team uh we have Deborah fener
director for housing and Alysia Norman
lead officer for overview and scrutiny
who are joining us via
teams
um we have quite a few staff that seem
to have got Co so we're a bit short on
the people that are present so can I
move to the agenda
please apologies for absence and
substitutions n receives
chair
item two to receive Declarations of
pecuniary other registrable or
non-registry
members item three we're going to
confirm the minutes of the Baba meeting
held on the 20th of November
2023 can I ask the committee are there
any points regarding the accuracy of the
minutes
anybody no could I have a proposal
please councelor Wyman councelor Smith
seconded that the um governance officer
will now conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
okay
councelor Smith may I take your vote
verbally can I take your vote
verbally thank you chair that five for
that's unanimous thank
you so that I'm just confirming that the
minutes of the Baba meeting on the 25
20th of November 2023 have been
confirmed to received notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none received
chair you questions by the public none
received chair questions by counselors
none received chair thank you we now go
to item s BOS Str 23
st05 general fund and housing revenue
account for
20242 and I would like to invite uh
councelor John Ward to introduce the
report to the committee thank you
councelor
ward thank you madam chairman I'm
pleased to introduce report BOS
2305 for the 2024 to 25 draft budget
covering both the general fund and H for
your consideration before it goes to
cabinet and then Council next month the
headlines are that the current draft
budget show a budget gap of 1.82 3
million pounds for the general fund and
a deficit for the HRA of 0.136 million P
just wanted to know that um in 1.4 that
that figure is incorrect it should be
10136 million for over a year we have
been experiencing huge cost pressures
due to global events and the consequent
High inflation and interest rates for
the current year we are at the end of
quarter 2 forecasting a deficit of
$962,000 for the general fund in
comparison with a small budget surplus
of £22,000 in February last
year similarly at quarter 2 the H
forecast is a deficit of 1.54 five
million compared with with the budget
deficit of £62,000
both these deficits will be financed by
borrowing from
reserves looking at the general fund in
detail the overall position for 2024 to
25 is shown in table one this shows new
cost pressures of just under 44.3
million identified Savings of 1.7
million and an increase in funding of
$724,000 plus last year's budget surplus
of £22,000 leading to the overall
deficit position of just over. 8 million
the summary is provided in table two and
details for the cost pressures and
savings are provided in tables three and
four just like to highlight at this
stage that um paragraph 4.2 says
February 2023 should say February 2024
there you will see from table two that
the net cost of service has increased by
21% while funding has increased by just
6% made up of 2.99% from a council tax
increase a 3.4% increase in Government
funding and a 9.9% % increase in
business rates although 2third of that
is from the removal of top slicing the
pooling benefit to suff public sector
leaders for this current
year more detail about the funding is
provided in paragraphs 4.7 to
4.11 the net cost of service includes
the changes to fees and charges agreed
by cabinet last month these include
those set by government which we can't
control and also those over which we do
have control and for which we have
adopted a policy of full cost recovery
the total for these is still slightly
down on the current Year's budget due to
the ongoing downturn in planning fee
income only partly mitigated by the
planning fee increases that the
government has announced
recently we're still reviewing possible
savings and efficiencies that can be
included in the 2024 to 25 budget but
the deficit isn't likely to be reduced
by much and it will be necessary to use
reserves to fund it as well as the
current year's forecast
overspend the year mark reserves
position is shown in table five we'll be
using 1.23 million to fund service
expenditure with 131 ,000 transferred to
the reserves at the moment the 2023 24
and the 24 to 25 deficit funding from
reserves isn't shown taking these into
account forecast level of air Mar
Reserves at the end of 2024 to 25
reduces to just under 4.6
million I am aware that Simon hore the
local government Minister has said that
we should use reserves but clearly this
is not a sustainable way of balancing
the budget in the long
term before moving on to the H I'll
conclude this review of the general fund
by saying that the forecast for the next
three years shows a worsening position
and therefore as soon as Council has
approved the budget for 2024 to 25 we
will embark on a program of identifying
further savings and efficiencies to put
the council's finances in a sustainable
and balanced position for the medium
term now looking at the HRA the summary
position for 20 24 to 25 is shown in
table six of the report although we are
expecting the inflationary pressures for
staff and contract material costs that
have resulted in an increase in Quarter
Two deficit for the current year to
continue into the next year the proposed
increases in rents and service charges
will more than offset this as you can
see the total cost of service has
increased by 1.62 million to 10% while
income has increased by 2.43 million p a
12% increase how however we are
proposing to do two things which will
result in a very large deficit of 9.53
five million pounds and a need to draw
heavily on Reserves
firstly there is a much larger Revenue
contribution to Capital of 4.48 million
proposed for the forthcoming year and
secondly there's a loan repayment of6
million due which we will repay rather
than
refinance coupled with the budget
deficit for the current year the total
deficit for 2024 to 25 is 10.36 million
pounds as I've said earlier but also um
as as I've also said quarter 2 is
showing a further deterioration for the
current year so the actual amount to be
financed from reserves will be
larger table seven shows the breakdown
for income and cost of service table
eight shows the pressures and table nine
shows the savings and income and
increase in
income Council housing rents are
increased by 7.7% which is equivalent to
an average rent increase of 7792 a week
for social rents and £113 a week for
affordable rents sheltered housing
service charges and utilities have risen
by an average of 37% to fully cover the
the cost increases and also so garage
garage rents are going to be increased
by RPI which is
8.9% I have mentioned that we'll be
financing the deficit from reserves the
full Reserve position is shown in table
10 the total Reserve reduction is
actually 9.36 n million which is the
10136 million budget deficit minus
767,000 of capital interest payments
going into the Strategic reserve and
that concludes my report Madam
chairman
can I check that um Alysia and Deborah
Fenson are online with
us yes and I can hear thank you
L can
somebody can you contact her thank you
all right uh before I proceed I am
really sorry um I forgot to welcome
counselor Busby a terrible oversight on
my over sight on my behalf counselor bu
B but nice to see you and I understand
you're here too for the second item on
our agenda so thank
you thank you I'd like to say it's a
pleasure to be at on this afternoon you
should be worried that I'm
here probably that was why I forgot to
introduce you but lovely to see
you
members you can now ask questions who's
going to start the questions councelor
Wyman thank you chairman um I assume
that um Council Ward would like to take
questions in segments so we don't get
too bogged down with too much detail um
the first question really which is it
will certainly help me and I think it
would help anyone who is watching online
is to try and lift the missed on
business rates um we've got four lines
um in table two which relate to business
rates um we've got a an overall
contribution of
676 uh, and a deficit of
93,000 could you perhaps explain how the
business rate issue works for the
council in relation to what we collect
and how much we get back from central
government um I will um pass over to
some of my colleagues but uh business
rates calculation is very
complicated um the it starts off from a
based position of 50% is taken by the
government 40% goes to the district
council and 10% to the County Council
however that 40% is reduced quite
considerably um uh by various
assessments that the government makes so
that we actually retain a far smaller
amount of that you'll see that and the
Baseline business rates line which is
$948,000
you've also got um the because we pull
uh the um the growth in business rates
across the county we have uh a share of
that we retain and also a share of that
normally goes to suff public sector
leaders but for the forthcoming year
that's not going to happen so that's
what those two pooling lines
represent uh the top slicing is is that
money that would have gone to suff
public sector leaders for the
forthcoming year but we're we're going
to retain that then you've got the
section 31 um Grant from government
which compensates US for um a number of
things that um we we can't charge for
this where we um providing business
rates reliefs and also where um
inflationary growth um there's there's
no increase in business rates year on
year and the government's compensating
us for that um I will pass over I think
I got most of that right have I is there
anything else that that needs to be
added to that um councelor I think you
got most of that right we have promised
in the finance team to do a plain
English briefing before Council on
business rates and where the various
allocations go to between the different
public bodies and how it's distributed
out to over o over nationally under the
government scheme and how we retain this
pot of money and it's quite complicated
it's um yeah the bane of our lives in
finance it's not it's not a very simple
system at all but we'll try to explain
it before Council and a written piece of
um paper that will be sent to you thank
you I mean the the the the complication
is I think is self-evident from the sort
of puzzle looks on people's faces even
yours Council award you didn't sort of
have your normal eloquence in terms of
explaining it um I think it's really
important because members of the public
will really need to understand this
because obviously this impacts upon our
overall funding but also on the issues
that we'll deal with later which relate
to the car parking side of it which I
think people will just need to
understand what the complexion is I
think the other question really is and
it's more a I suppose
a sort of finger in the air one uh is
which way do you expect the rating
conversation to go with central
government is it likely to be going in
our favor or against
us that is a very interesting question
at the moment um it's like the having a
longm term uh Local Government funding
review and settlement uh the government
has postponed um any review of business
rates Year from year to year for a
number of years now um we have no idea
to be honest my gut feel is that um I
can't see a district like babber coming
out of it more favorably than we are at
the moment when when it finally does
come around whether it's this government
or any future
government thank
you councilor Grand
um please can you explain the section
regarding
CCO I don't quite understand it it says
interest
receivable um is that income from our
investments please could you explain
that uh yes that's the the money that
CCO pays to us um uh from from the um
rental income that they they get get
from the
properties councelor
J so following on from C Council Grand
com so what what has caused the
reduction in the interest received from
cifco there is uh some of that um money
is is not being repaid for um because
it's been retained by CCO for Capital
Improvements um there has been
um a deferred rental um rental payments
have been agreed for a few years but um
uh it's also based on on the actual
rental income that that that's um uh the
CCO gets year on
year councelor
Smith um you obviously you don't work
with a crystal ball and there's a lot of
uncertainty with inflation interest
rates
grants and things how
much um give is there in your estimate
um you I presume it's a worst case
scenario that that you put into the
report for this this budget you're
referring to um well it's there's a lot
of um work that's gone in in terms of
looking at the cost pressures looking at
savings um uh this the local government
funding settlement um ccil tax um
increase that we're proposing 2.99% all
of that together um has gone into uh the
the numbers we've got here and also um
projecting forward for the next three
years into the medium term um where you
see and and we'll be showing that in in
the budget papers going to cabinet and
then Council you'll see how that will
change over the next three to four years
and it's it's not an improving
situation it's the projections I'm
talking about you can't you can't be
never be no because we we we don't know
um what the local government funding
settlements are going to be each year um
we we don't obviously don't know the um
the various inflationary pressures we
can make some assumptions some guesses
based on on what we can see at the
moment but um obviously the further you
go into the future the the less certain
that's going to
be do you want to add anything to that
Karen I would just add as well that we
do take advice on certain aspects of the
budget again they're estimates but we're
taking advice from um you
know external advisers who know um you
know specialize in that sort of area so
for example I'll in close we take advice
on the interest rates that we should be
projecting uh forwards um and we we look
at bodies like the budget for office
responsibility for inflation rates so we
try and get the best advice available
but you're quite right there's still
estimates and we don't have that crystal
ball
councilor bus sorry sorry can I just add
to that I think I think one thing that
we haven't talked about and there's no
reason that we should is that the fact
we are entering an um a general election
period you would think that any
additional funds that are available are
going to be used perhaps on the
individual person rather than uh things
like local government whatever so
I'll be very suspicious of anything that
was promised I suspect we're going to
get nothing it's going to be worse than
nothing
possibly and if you heard this morning
that the know schools are in D Straits
the hospitals in D Strait so there's a
great deal of competition for any money
that isn't going to the individual so
you know could it get any worse I don't
know hope
not
Council councelor grden and then councel
W I think I'm covering a similar Point
actually
um it seems to be noticed finally that
um local government is in need of funds
um and um it's been in the national and
local press so if that was to come to
fruition do you think we'd be talking
about this year or next year
we're not going to see anything
different this year um there's been
pressure for for many years from the LGA
from the DCM from the CCN um for uh a
much better and more realistic
settlement yes there's been a lot more
uh clamor in the Press recently because
of the um section 114 notices that some
councils have issued and only today yes
we've got the MPS um who've written um
requesting um far more a better better
settlement for local government um
because they they are concerned about
the impact on services that that we
deliver um but realistically I I can't
see that um this this final settlement
for 2425 is going to be much different
from what we know
already you'd agree with that
Kon yes not least because this is the
end of what they call the spending
review period by Central governments so
every three or four years central
government will review how much each
central government department will
receive and obviously local government
gets its funding from duu Department of
leveling up communities and housing and
um our settlement was um the second year
of a two-year fixed term settlement and
the next spending review will be in 19
um 2025 so after the election so there
won't be any movement on this figure
that we've been given provisionally PRI
to Christmas in the final set settlement
we
receive yes CU I mean it's being talked
about by cabinet members and so on at
the moment isn't it so you think that's
going to come to
nothing but it was only 40 out of what
320 so one in eight I don't think MPS
really give two Hoops about local
government quite frankly and these were
backbench MPS they weren't cabinet uh
government
Michael go has been he he didn't sign
that L as
well um was in the um times yesterday
online he he might he has he hasn't
promised any more money for local
councils thank
you can I just ask committee members to
speak into your microphones please that
would be really helpful and for
everybody at the end as well world we
the sound is not very good in this
chamber when there's very few people
councelor
Wyman a $10 million
question um we have a legal requirement
to deliver a balanced
budget clearly that's not something
we're going to accomplish that easily
this year or as we go into it we're
going to have to call on
reserves um the Blue Sky the Blue Sky
question really is when when will do you
think we'll be able to deliver a
balanced budget without having to dip
into our reserves and what strategic
plan do we have in place to accomplish
this well we're going to have to assume
because our reserves won't last um more
than another year or so um in terms of a
strategic plan as I said as soon as this
budget is approved by Council um that we
will be looking at what we can do to put
the council's finances on on a stable
footing going forward so that means that
obviously the chief executive senior
leadership team will looking we looking
at exactly how um uh what what services
we can deliver what things are going to
cost how we more importantly how we're
going to deliver Services uh going
forward I don't know chief executive if
you want to come in and give some of
your thoughts which I know you have it
was partially aimed at the chief
executive action it's very kind if you
counselor um so just to give some
reassurance so we aren't Council Ward's
absolutely right in terms of work we'll
start in earnest beyond the budget but
as you can expect we're not waiting till
then uh so those conversations have been
happening for several months now in
terms of what that might look like
bluntly I think it's very simple in
terms of councils uh because either we
increase our income or we decrease our
costs uh or in reality both uh and we
need to be in the both territory hence
given the size of the challenge that we
face um and you are in a people business
uh so your main cost is Staffing so we
will need to be looking at what we don't
do
um now part of that as councilor Ward
alluded to is I personally think that
there is a structural Financial issue
not in Baba's finances but in local
government finances uh but we're not in
a position to fix that on our own
because it requires government to
structurally fix it and just coming back
to the conversation you were just having
I have zero confidence the government is
going to provide any additional funding
to local government and if it does I
think it will go to send I think it will
go to social care I think it might go to
potholes I think it go nowhere near
district and B Ser district and borrow
Council Services apart perhaps from
things like homelessness uh so we do
periodically when there I suspect when
there's an underspend within deu uh we
get given dollops of cash again coming
back to the planning point you can't
plan for dollops of cash it's very nice
to have but it's very difficult to plan
for but specifically that's around
tackling homelessness occasionally in
relation to disabled facilities grants
as well but when you think about the
breadth of services we provide that
doesn't touch the sides so for me I
think we need to be looking
fundamentally about a complete redesign
of what local government looks like uh
that might sound like going back to well
what's statutary what's discretionary I
don't really mean that because I suspect
your residents our residents value the
discretionary things more than the
statutary things so I don't think it
should be as simple as well we'll just
do the knitting and not worry about the
rest because you all got elected I'm
sure in order to make a difference not
just provide transactional services and
turn the handle uh and so we need to be
fundamentally thinking about how we can
restructure things and of course in our
context that means a conversation with M
suff as well because what you do has a
bearing on them and vice versa so it's
not something we will look at in
glorious isolation from mids suffk orbe
it their financial position as we stand
today is not as acute but it looks like
it heads in the same direction
relatively quickly so it makes sense for
them to be at that table as well so no
specific proposals at this point but we
will work through that what I'm not
going to ask you to do as counselors is
is tell me which Services you value most
and the reason I say that is because
there will be things that you rightly
from a representative perspective will
not put top of the list but as an
organization we still have to do those
things whether that's HR whether that's
Finance whether that's it whether that's
elections those things are not going to
be high on the Public's agenda or
necessarily on your political agenda but
we still have to be able to function as
an organization but how we go about
doing that is absolutely we are at the
point now we need to critically think
differently and like W says my view is
the reserves may be able to balance the
budget this year we're not there yet but
may be able to balance this year and
then they are gone so we need to set the
budget relying upon those reserves and
then try desperately not to use them in
the next financial year so that we don't
eat into the actually eat into those
reserves but then the budget challenge
becomes another two million the
following year another two million the
following year it doesn't get any easier
it only gets
harder sorry to be
depressing thank you you I think anyone
who listing online would find that
reassuring to know that we do have a
plan in place and we do we are albeit at
an early stage considering how we can
manage what we're facing which is
clearly quite a a difficult situation
thank you thank
you thank you
chair uh in section 4.5 he say mentions
um could be a revenue budget pressure
arising from the forecast loss on the
housing development in had
former HQ at Hadley uh what is the
forecast loss and um would it have
pressure on this year's budget next
year's budget what sort of pressures
would it put on
us um I can't give you a final number
for that just yet um we're still working
on that and uh exactly when that's going
to to kick in but um uh there might be
when we come to look at the the
monitoring of uh 2024 25 budget going
through the year leading to the outturn
um we we might see some pressures as a
result of that in in in those those
documents as we go
forward is that about right do you think
most of it or some of it will be in the
next year rather than going beond that
um well some of it Council might well be
in this year's budget you're quite right
we're still working with aring close to
see what impact um a potential loss on
baby growth limited will have on the
revenue budget uh given the likelihood
of government introducing new
regulations
determining um the accounting and
financing of lending to third party
organizations so it's still it's still
work in progress I think would be fair
to
say so we got a clue if we're talking in
pounds thousands or Millions all
yeah
I wouldn't like to give a number at this
stage but it's it's going to be
significant we need to get the project
finished leaving the building derelict
is not an option so we just have to to
go through and there have been huge um
unex unexpected increases in costs for
various reasons inflationary costs
obviously with in materials and labor um
but also there's additional Works due to
things that have been found when
um uh things were exposed um asbestos
that sort of thing um issues with listed
buildings and a number of other things
there's been all sorts of um project
related costs there that were
unanticipated but we've got to just go
through and complete the project
Tom just to to flag alongside the the
costs obviously one part of the equation
is The Ultimate Sales values um so at
some point you're going to get to somewh
where the work's complete and we're
forecasting those sales values at the
moment but tracking the value within the
housing market is you know very
difficult to very difficult to do so
again that's another reason why setting
down figures at this stage isn't
necessarily particularly helpful albeit
it might give you a bit more kind of
understanding of where things are but
ultimately those End Sales values will
have a significant impact on what the
overall outturn of that project is which
could be better than anticipated or
worse than anticipated of
course right so um just on that so the
forecast for next year was it 2.2
million I think deficit at the moment
for is that for not not 2425 25
26 could be worse could be even worse
than year could be better but it could
be worse is that
right I'm not going to um give any
numbers on I'm afraid councelor Jameson
it's U for the reasons that I and and
and Tom have have stated it it would be
unfair to to put any value on on things
at the
moment councelor Jameson I think in
other Arenas there's been a discussion
about this and I think we have to
wait councelor
gr thank you um obviously the the um
former HQ was going to be an income
generating project for us um and now
it's gone in the opposite
direction
um which is very concerning I think
um one of the things as a member of on
that I would like to see for the council
meeting is that we have a paper
explaining some of the background to
this because obviously it's such a big
and important project for the council
and is possibly part of the reason for
the re for our losses is it or perhaps
you could explain that
um but I I would like to see especially
as a member for Hadley I would like to
see some explanation brought to the
council as to the background around to
um the project in in our old our former
headquarters so that the council as a
whole can look at
it and the phase one of that development
was only yet ever expected to break even
um and uh but in terms of this current
budget there's nothing in the paper in
front of you that relates to uh costs
for cours Lane uh Redevelopment um uh
I think that at some point in the
fullness of time yes we might be able to
bring some uh a separate paper back to
to council to um uh once the Project's
finished once the properties have sold
then then we know the final numbers but
um it's going to be sometime before
we're in that position um and also
obviously we need to um make sure that
we don't breach any uh commercial
confidentiality with with our contractor
there
thank you councelor grandon I think
you've got to accept that at the
moment uh it's not for this meeting I
don't think to for us to be discussing
that thank you I'd like to ask some
questions as the chair you get the last
sort of end of it don't you um on page
12 we we see that the backlog of repairs
has has created um an increase obviously
in the expenditure well I know we've
recently changed
subcontractors are we seeing a bigger
increase because of that uh the new
contractors taking over the
work sorry you're talking about the um H
um page it was page 12
3.3
perhaps oh the H yes main uh CPI
increases on the number of contracts
increasing cost ass yes so if if that's
in the uh for the uh position in in the
current year 23 to 24 um and we we
looked at that last looked at that in
December when cabinet looked at the
quarter two position for that um we have
uh there have been significant
inflationary uh costs on
uh the work that we and and an increase
in the amount of work that we've had to
do on our stock and that will continue
into the forthcoming year there is a
we're carrying out a full stock survey
at the moment and um we are expecting to
have to spend a significant amount of
money which we have budgeted for in the
HRA section of this paper yeah because
obviously a different contractor is
going to have as high costs as the
previous contractor but um we we've got
a lot of the the work in house now but
we are still using external um
contractors for for some of that um I
don't know is Deborah Fenton uh on the
cour um maybe she'd be able to yeah
Deborah could you put some more detail
on that please
yes yes of course so so to give members
a little bit of um context um so we've
had a a range of of challenges one being
that we had um as of um I think it was
may we we we had seven ,000 outstanding
jobs and we did bring an outside
contractor in um to help us get on top
of those jobs and um I don't know the
exact figure but I know that those jobs
are now sitting under um 2,000 so so
that's been a huge Improvement and
obviously that's um had an in uh an
additional cost um members will also be
aware that we did change our contractor
from Aon Services over to signit and we
increased uh the workload um and really
wanted to get up to date on on our all
our work on on heating um so that's been
a significant um additional cost and
also members will be aware um that um
you know the the this Council as well as
all other councils have got increasing
issues with damper mold in their
properties and we did um engage an
external contractor and they're still
actually with us at the moment to go out
and do damp inspect ctions um and and
putting uh additional Works to try and
deal with that so so that that gives you
a very quick overview of some of the
additional costs um which we've incurred
and obviously that doesn't go doesn't it
go into things like inflation and and
higher costs
Etc thank you
deorah my next question is on page 14 of
the page
uh I I'm I'm asking this question really
for people that might be looking in from
parishes about neighborhood planning
income could somebody just explain that
to me uh there's a reduction in
neighborhood planning income could could
somebody explain that statement to me
please which paragraph you looking at
Madam
chairman in the
oh yes yes it's about halfway down the
table Tom are you able to comment on
that I'm able to go into it a little bit
so essentially when an area is
designated an amount of Grant comes into
the council itself to help support the
costs of neighborhood plans so that's
things like referendum costs and
advertising so it's not the it's not the
costs of the neighborhood plan work sit
with the parish council because they
access grant funding through locality
for specialist advice and other things
like that what this refers to is the
grant that comes in from areas that are
designated and then when neighborhood
plans are made so when they um post
referendum um when they're adopted but
it's called made then there's a further
amount that comes through um so it's
anticipating a reduction in that from
what had previously been forecast
thanks Tom that's
helpful I mean just to just to add to
that if parishes are watching there is
uncertainty about the grants that go
directly to parishes because much like
we're only getting annual settlements
and we get them last minute government
are also giving very last minute advice
on the grants that would be available to
communities that started as a six-year
approach that you know you get 20 000
per neighborhood plan and an amount of
money per neighborhood plan that then
reduced and they've then over the last
three years only been giving
onee extensions of what that funding
would be so the funding available to
communities to complete their neighbor
plans is less certain than it was when
they started albeit there's
no signal from government that they
value neighborhood plans any less so we
would anticipate that money will
continue but it comes very last minute
and confirmation of it comes very last
minute
unfortunately you I've got another
planning question
actually sorry about that um when we
look at
um all the planning income is is
reduced uh this is an important service
many of us have sat on planning
committees what are the implications of
that reduction in the planning
income um I think the first thing to say
is that there isn't a direct line
relationship between the workload that
the planning service is dealing with and
the fee income that is dealing with
ultimately major applications on the
whole cross-
subsidize minor applications so an
application for a single dwelling you
get about £450 for 200 dwellings you get
200 lots of £450 you probably don't do
200 times the amount of work so um what
what we've seen is a significant
reduction in major fee income um we
haven't seen a significant reduction in
workload um because single house still
takes a lot of work to to determine um
so work coming to planning committee
will continue um The Joint local plan
itself probably changes the dynamic
because of where we've been at there
isn't a need hasn't been a need for
quite so many applications um but as we
work on part two um which will be
happening between now and summer next
year um we'll be looking at allocating
more development and I would I would
anticipate that you likely to see some
major applications follow that process
through so they might try to preempt the
the making of the the um part two plan
you see a few more major
applications um it's quite difficult to
forecast the housing market has been
less buoyant but our own planning
documents are also less encouraging I
suppose of of significant significant
development and a stronger so you're
likely to see fewer
um speculative type applications um than
you've seen in the past because having
adopted the local plan you've got a
stronger planning
framework
um but other than that
the the challenge is that things could
change at any moment um and the the
housing market picks up Suddenly you
might see a few more speculative
applications come in applications you
weren't anticipating but likewise
planning isn't just about housing So
within Baba for example over the last
couple of months you've seen two
applications for um solar Farms come in
where significant amount of fee income
that comes from those um or a meaningful
amount of fee income that comes from
those but you can't anticipate
necessarily how many of those you're
going to get and likewise employment
applications they also carry a fee that
comes with them um and you're likely to
see some employment you're likely to see
some renewable energy um and you're
likely to continue to see some housing
there will have been outline
applications that need to be filled in
with Reserve matters Reserve matters
comes with a fee um but we have seen a
significant reduction in fee income this
year quite how long that lasts is is um
kind of like everything else you can
forecast you you can be more confident
in your forecasting the Clos you are to
to whatever period you're forecasting so
what that means for four years
time um it's is
difficult thank you madam chair um yes
I'd like to ask a couple of questions
please um regarding tables table three
for for example what are HR and
organizational development
costs and the other one is rent and
rates on Old HQ building I presume
that's moving around of money and paying
ourselves sort of thing is it um please
could you explain those
two I'll ask the chief executive to
answer the HR and organizational
development costs but um I I think in
terms of the old HQ building
um there must be some residual business
rates that we we're responsible for
while we're going through the the
development Redevelopment
process yeah I'm getting a that's kind
of paying ourselves then is it like
circular no that's not how it works no
it isn't
okay y thank you chair thank you Council
in terms of the HR and organization
organizational development costs that's
the money we spend investing in training
and developing our staff I'm sorry
that's the money we spend investing in
training and developing our staff uh so
that's increased proportionately uh it's
a difficult one because uh my personal
view is at a time where you potentially
shrink your Workforce you need to invest
more in them because you need even
greater skills rather than uh less
skills but that's what that is thank
you councilor
Wyman thank you chair may I steerers
away into the HRA
um side please um quick question and
sort of semi observation really table
seven top of dwelling rents uh 2.78
million um if we move on to that equates
to a
7.7% increase in our Baseline figures
for uh social housing and I assume
affordable housing rents um
the sector the private sector generally
across South subok is plus 1 plus
177% in the last 12 months um that's
putting significant pressure on private
rentals um the question I have really
centers around an element of reassurance
I think from again anyone who's
listening would be as I understand it
the people who are most vulnerable will
get support towards their incre inrees
7.7% in the social housing and
affordable housing
rentals there has been some increase in
the local housing allowance component of
um support from government so um uh they
will benefit from that but um obviously
that there's there's only a limit on
what what that can provide um again
Deborah are you able
to provide any more detail on that I I
am yet members so we do have um a couple
of financial inclusion officers in our
Housing Solutions team and they um work
with tenants and and um actually
residents um across both districts so
they will be able to offer support for
for those people who are struggling um
in addition to that it's it's um I need
to also say that um those increases will
be covered by housing benefit for those
people or or or housing um payment
if they're on universal credit for those
people who've got that
entitlement thank you CH ring you thank
you
Deborah
Jameson on the H um account don't think
I've seen any long-term forecasts on
that where we have on the general fund
is that um is there any long-term
position for the H or if I miss
something the um HRA 30-year business
plan is is being reviewed and there will
be an update on that coming through soon
um again Deborah are you able to provide
any more detail on that and the time T
table for that
please I am yes there will be an update
to the um HRA business plan going to
full
Council in I think it's
March and that and that will that that
will provide a 30-year position um um
for
members thank you a followup question uh
to Deborah really and I think it sort of
follows again from the point you rais
chair which was the the point on
building uh Services transformation the4
54,000 is that a semi oneoff cost or is
that something which would be a
potentially ongoing charge over the next
year so I assume that relates to our
transformation from uh Contracting
Services to
directs um um sorry members J Jenny can
I just ah Jen Jenny has just messaged me
that is the
oneoff um so so at the moment we do have
a lot of um interim members of Staff in
because of um transformation and one of
those is um a consultant so those are um
oneoff members of staff however there
there will be um changes to the budget
which are already accounted for um in in
this um in our in our budget proposals
for the new DLo
structure thank you you thank you any
more
questions I've just got one last one
thank you um on page 13 about the
service
expenditure uh which talks about
supplies and services and this is quite
High an increase of
th000 does that those supplies and
services does that include some of the
specialist advice we get like Arlen
close or um where where we have a
project and we bring in an outside
company does that is that is that that
total thank
you I will pass over to um Karen to
provide the detail on on that or or Sean
can you SE Sean
will uh yes it will it will include that
spend um if it's not if there spend on a
particular project uh that we're getting
expert expertise in from outside um as
as we said previously that we would try
and capitalize that cost if it was part
of a capital project um if it's um
it could well be within consultancy
spend under supplies and services
otherwise it would be in the the third
party payments in the major contract
stuff but it would be supplies and
services in there yeah can I just follow
that up with another one
then is that some is that an area that
we ought to be
reviewing in terms of how we use outside
expertise thank you yes thanks built
into next year budget is a savings
program where we're aiming to reduce
contract spend and and and get that
figure down so there is a there's also
some use of reserves where we we we can
spend to save if you like so there will
be that is part of that 557 line on that
main table is uh contract spend making
sure that we're using our procurement
Services making sure people using um you
know suppliers that are approved
suppliers and we're targeting the spend
through those suppliers rather than
going
elsewhere thank
you have we finished with the questions
committee councilor Grant and do you
have another one that
you right first of all I'd like to thank
everybody for the response that was um
which jum about a bit on the paper but
thank you very much for that
um as there's no further questions I
will open it up for
debate who would like to start the
debate councelor
Wyman thank you chair
um I can see what a really tough job it
must be to try
and balance all our expectations in
terms of services we want to deliver
deliver um the cost of those services
and the current difficulties with
funding generally and I found it really
reassuring to know that as CEO and the
senior leadership team have got um the
process in Hand of looking more
strategically at how we can improve um
and look at the overall configurations
perhaps of the authority to some extent
um
it's easy not easy I think it's it's
reasonably clear that we have
duplications of cost in certain areas
and those cost
duplications things that we possibly
could have afforded five or even more
years ago those costs based on what
you've all said this morning which is
the
shortterm uh funding of local government
clearly um are things we can't continue
to afford and we need to look really
close mostly and scrutinize how we go
forward in terms of the the the the
Democratic services and all the services
that we offer and at the same time in
the back of our minds we still need to
remember that we represent communities
that have less money to spend there's
pressures and we need to be mindful of
those pressures and make sure that we
manage them to the best of our ability
um
I mean I would like to say that I mean
it is a difficult situation we're
in and um we have got to be we are
elected by the electorate to ensure that
wise decisions are
made and
uh our residents rely on us to look at
all the
possibilities are on
offer um and I think it's
important that we give this a lot of due
thought uh when you see the figures then
they
don't add up to um a very good picture
for us in B so it's important that we
recognize our responsibility to make
sure that money is spent in the best
possible Manner and that might not suit
all of us
unfortunately so members of the
committee any more comments on the
[Music]
paper are there any oh sorry councelor
best I think it's I think it's important
that we realize that times are tough
but we get a very small percentage of
the overall council tax 9%
10% which is amounts to a few few pounds
per week perhaps we provide an
unbelievable level of service on a
number of fronts for that money the
residents should be proud of what babber
does they certainly couldn't get the
services from anybody else from anywhere
near the price that we charge of
them so I just think that it is tough
and we are going to fight and we will
fight we have to fight to make sure we
get a balanced budget but we should also
Pat ourselves on the back occasionally
and say that we do do a good job it
should be
recognized councelor wman could I go
back on on on councilor buy point he's
absolutely spot on we do provide amazing
services to our residents and one of the
things which I sort of
just just glanced at and noticed was the
price of emptying the dog
bins we support dog bins at some
ludicrously low rate and I don't mind
this being a public comment um why do we
actually it's a question as well this is
why and what process do we go through to
set that discounting policy where we're
actually spending money to empty dog
bins I mean our Parish councils vary
from you know small rural par councils
to larger ones and town
councils I would imagine that that's
something which many of our parishes
going back on Sho Council of Busby and
town councils could well afford to carry
the full cost of so I'd like to question
observation really but it' just be
interested to know what process we go
through to actually arrive at that 30%
or 40% discount that we appli to those
services award would you like to resp I
mean in terms of the the dog I'm just
looking at the um uh we're increasing
from 4653 to 69 um it's still not quite
full cost Rec recovery but um uh that
the the dog and litter bins are the only
two Services where I I believe um from
memory where we are not yet going to hit
that full cost recovery simply because
it would have been a huge um increase in
in one year so over the next two to
three years we will get up to full cost
recovery for that but you're right um uh
we have in the past not been charging
nearly enough for for dog and lit bin
emptying and we are getting there um
even now the The Proposal um that £69
for dog bins and little bins for the
forthcoming year is still good value for
money it's just over a pound a
week it's certainly not a service I'd
like to pick up councelor order to know
that sorry sorry the final Point really
was I sometimes think in this just a
general point in relation to cost and
efficiencies but our Parish councils
have great infrastructures and there are
many ways and means we can deploy to
help save money for the district by
deploying Services into parishes and
there are many parish counil that quite
willing to do those services and if I
may say so we'll probably do it better
than we can and that gives us lots of
opportunity to look at the way we
devolve our services and as as you know
some Parish councils clearly may not
want to take on that responsibility but
there are some quite significant parish
and town councils that can take on those
responsibilities and I think there's
certainly some marish to be considered
in relation to deployment or the off of
deployment of those Services into parish
and town
councils I totally agree with that and
and we will be looking at that more and
more in the years to
come thank you Council wman thank you
Council
Ward oh
just going to say um whatever way we
look at it with 1.8 million pound
deficit there is going to be some kind
of effect on Services even if it's comes
down just to cut in
staff um that will have a knock on
effect on the services we provideed so
it's going to be difficult I'm sure
we're going to get some uh push back and
some um negative comments going forward
in the next year if services are
affected and it's something that I think
we're going to have to take on board and
um spin it as best we can or work it way
as best we can but yeah I
mean we've such a big deficit and
possible deficits in the
future can't see how we're going to
recover such uh a lot such a hull
without some kind of effect on
service councelor Smith will you want to
say something something thank you just
following on from Council Jameson I
think public engagement is key to
letting people know what's happening and
why it's happening
um otherwise people will become angry
without understanding the pressures
we're
facing this paper is
forting and we can add some additional
recommendations
members would you like to add any
additional recommendations to
this what about the one you suggested
councelor
Smith um I'm I'm sure the media office
is already um you were talking about
engagement with with the public wer you
yes I I'm I'm thinking making sure a
press release
reflects the pressures that we're
under
so Beth are you coming up with something
that's just doing
that then you can read it back any more
recommendations C councel grundon would
you like to make some
recommendations you're thinking about
it councelor Wyman chairman I certainly
like it sounds like Council W is already
on the case in relation to deployment of
services but I certainly think that's
something we should really look closely
at and scrutinize in terms of what we
can do to improve our position both in
terms of improving the quality of our
service but at the same time saving the
district um money would you like to put
that into some sort
of Beth have you finished councelor
Smith or would you like to read it
back so what I've written down is that
engagement with the public be encouraged
to outline budget pressures on the
council Council Smith was there any
practical engagement is with the public
is a wide
remit is there something more specific
you could um you would like to
suggest I'm sure it's already in hand
but a um immediate and
ongoing media
releases to make the public aware or
some
actual um visits
by perhaps officers or perhaps officers
could engage with Parish
councils
right is that
acceptable monitoring officer I'm not
having that responsibility um it is but
if I may politely push back you will
attend your parish and Council parish
and Town Council meetings already you're
already there we've got 180 across the
districts um we've just been talking
about the lack of Officer resource to
deliver the services we need to deliver
I think this would be an extra burden
rather than trying to save money but the
need I think I was going to make the
more broad point I suppose which is
there is a fundamental lack of
understanding and I am generalizing
amongst our residents about local
government the bits that the towns do
the bits that the parish does the bits
the district does the bits that the
county does how they're funded um and so
we're starting on the back foot because
what we're trying to say we no longer do
this I didn't know you did that
um we can no long afford to do this I
didn't know what I paid towards you so I
do think there is a wider educational
piece that collectively both councilors
and officers can do and through towns
and parishes you're absolutely right to
try and get that out there um ideally
that would start in school but I'm not
going to suggest that for at this stage
but that would be very helpful um and
I'm mindful that the cabinet have
already put a press release out that is
much more bullish than we've ever been
before basically saying as I said
earlier there's a structural problem
here um government you needs to
intervene uh and for those that are
following kind of the TR local
government trade press uh we are one of
hundreds that have been saying exactly
the same thing day after today um but as
I said earlier I'm not sure government's
listening but at the very least we do
need uh to try and make sure that our
residents at least understand what we're
trying to do and the challenges we face
because ultimately we're providing
services for them uh and if we're going
to fundamentally change how we do it we
need to make sure that that's done with
them not to
them um per perhaps there could be a
meeting with Parish councils invited to
speak to the chief executive um ask
questions be informed absolutely we have
regular town and Parish Le aison
meetings so more than happy to do it
through one of those yeah precisely that
yes thank you Arthur I mean I think
having had a very successful the last
Parish leaz a meeting we had was a very
successful one um perhaps we could um
develop that idea can you just reread
then um Beth what
um so what I've got written down is that
engagement with the public be encouraged
to outline budget pressures on the
council with ongoing media
releases through the medium of Parish
Leo meetings does that sound better yeah
okay
that
CH would you like me to read
mine
thank you chair yes I would the district
Authority actively consider the
deployment of certain services to town
and Parish councils who have an appetite
to accept functions currently undertaken
by District Sorry by Bor
Services the district Authority actively
consider the deployment of services to
town Parish councils who have an
appetite to accept functions currently
undertaken by babber
services that that has been considered
before hasn't
it uh it's been discussed in the past
and certainly we can look to see how we
can accelerate that exactly as as Castle
Worman says devolving Services down to
towns and parishes depending on the
nature of the service um we may still
hold the legal responsibility for it
albeit they car work in other
circumstances particularly if it's
discretionary then we would simply stop
and they would simply start um most of
those conversations if not all I won't I
won't totally generalize certainly have
uh the towns and parishes have been very
clear and not unreasonably in terms of
saying well we might be interested um
but we want the asset if it is an asset
improved before we take it on or we
might be interested but we'd like some
conf uh confidence of some kind of
subsidy um for a period of time that
kind of thing um but certainly the last
town of Parish leaon meeting there was
definitely a a willingness to explore
that from pretty much all of the
parishes that were in the room um the
only caveat I would add and it's not a
caveat to not doing it um but that
doesn't necessarily of course result in
savings to the district council um
because you start if I take grass
cutting as a very simple example um if
the parish would like to cut the grass
in their Parish uh either to a higher
standard or to the standard we currently
achieve um we've got the kit um we have
officers deployed in other areas so
there isn't a kind of direct correlation
between just because they're doing it
means that you necessarily save the full
cost but frankly everything has to be on
the table so why wouldn't we explore
it Beth can you read that that
recommendation out and
see you missed half a bit can you set
again Council
one the district Authority actively
consider the deployment of services to
town and Parish
councils who have an appetite to accept
functions currently undertaken by laor
Services just following on to the G
Executives Point um anecdotally um and I
can only speak for my residents in C
really um we have a real mish mash of of
crossover Services between mowing who
does this who does that who owns this is
who owns that and there's so much scope
for improvement and efficiencies that
it's it's just a case of just get
getting down to the the nitty-gritty of
who's doing what and who who can do it
best and what's the least cost
associated with that
service councelor grandon you had a
recommendation
no thank you yeah was just really in
response to what our CU executive saying
um a bit earlier in as much as
um in my view the um parish and town
councils do have understanding of what
we do but the
public do not and I would completely
agree with ar executive they don't know
which Council does what unless they have
a personal experience of a service
they think that we do nothing apart from
the
bins um and um I think it's no bad thing
for they they that the public think that
because we collect the um council tax
that we take the council tax and so um
maybe in in a way that um
someone can find an appropriate way of
communicating it um it would be no bad
thing to explain to the public rather
than um parish and town
councils what the district council does
for them because if you look at this
long list that we've been seeing here
today I think um most people would be
surprised um um I can think of some nice
sort of PR type ideas but then of course
there's cost involved in that so um you
know it may may or may not be
appropriate but um you know I think
um what where when people see their
council tax rise and so on they wonder
what they're getting for that seeing
some of these lists of what we do as a
council will make people realize what
what we do do so you know there are
certain things that that you know would
be nice if there's the opportunity not
too much costs for comms to communicate
to the
residents about our
activities
um so I just wanted to make that that
statement really and may maybe if you
know if it's possible to do an action
depending on on activity levels
and and programs you know and and and
costs I mean the cost and resources are
a big factoring that AR
they they are up to a point yes um and
obviously we've increased our presence
online in particular things like
Instagram Facebook um trying to make
sure that we're reaching out to as many
residents as possible that access that
kind of uh material appreciate that not
every resident will be uh on those
platforms um but certainly increased the
type of uh communication that we put out
so that it's less about the service
there more human related stories um so
that you would for example the most
recent one that Springs to mind that we
plant trees you wouldn't necessarily
know that we plant trees as you say
you'd know that we're the ones who send
you your bill uh and you'd know that
we're the ones that collect your bins
but beyond that you start to get a bit
hazy certainly certainly other
authorities have gone down the rout of
regular newsletters so hard copy
newsletters sent to every household that
clearly starts to incur a proper cost
should we say and also quite a lot of
resource because you can imagine the
level of um editing and scrutiny that
goes into those words to make sure that
the right communication goes out rather
than just sending out anything um but it
is proven to work um so that there is a
balance there in terms of broadly
speaking those authorities that send out
that kind of communication their
residents believe that they provide
better value for money even though
they're doing exactly the same services
and spending more money to tell them the
perception is that they provide better
value for money so I think we should
again as I said earlier we're starting
from quite a low base in terms of
people's awareness and I'm generalizing
I think that would be an important thing
to do what while I've got the flaw chair
the life of type articles and
absolutely there was just one thing I
was going to add into the uh into
awareness not to the debate or questions
but just to to highlight that I don't
think has come up thus far is that a lot
alongside the strains that we've talked
about in terms of our budgets the
pressures Etc what we will also
experience are the impacts of other
public sector Services withdrawing their
services in order to balance their books
uh so purely as one example we know that
there is a direct correlation between if
the County Council and I say if I think
it's highly likely but if the County
Council withdraw their support for
housing related support so this is the
wraparound support that goes around
certain individuals to make sure they
can stay in their t
tencies you can imagine that if you
remove that support more of those
tencies fail if those tencies fail
that's our resp that's our
responsibility because we have the
statute of responsibility for
homelessness so it's not just the budget
pressures that we directly face as the
district council it's also trying to
predict and understand the additional
demands that will come on to some of our
services as everybody tightens their
belts thank
you
count and the budgets that we' reviewed
today would you add y so there's the
additional recommendations that
engagement with the public specifically
through media releases and turn leers on
meetings be encouraged to help outline
and provide Clarity to the public
regarding the budget pressures on the
council and that the district Authority
actively considers the deployment of
certain services to town and Parish
councils who have an appetite to accept
full accept functions currently carried
out by B District
Council are members of the committee
happy with
that then can I we we can um now go to
the vot vot so can I have a
proposal please for those
recommendations councelor Jamon second
councelor
Wyman thank you chair that bate is now
in progress please can you
vote thank you chair that's five votes
for that's
unanimous thank
you that's the end of um our first item
but I would like to thank on behalf of
the committee all the officers and
counselors Ward and Busby who have come
today and and participated in our
session and we just want to say thank
you there is a lot of work that goes
into the preparation of our
budgets and uh we appreciate apprciate
all the work that's been done by all all
the officers involved in finance and in
all the other things that have produced
this um report today so thank you very
much committee I think we need to take
10 minutes are you happy with that we'll
take a 10 minutes break thank
you
thank you and I'm going to uh continue
with the
agenda
and um oh did I have to so sorry yes do
you want Count Me
In we're already in thank you we're
continueing now with the agenda I'm on
agenda item eight
b236 update on car parking charges and
I'm delighted to invite councelor Busby
to introduce the report to the committee
thank you thank you feel like the
sacrificial
lamb um good afternoon car parking as if
nobody knew anything about it look there
are three real reasons why we've got
this paper um coming up um you might be
surprised that I said three and not just
one first of all it's budgetary
pressures and financial fairness
secondly it's that we've just completed
a strategic review of parking and
thirdly and I think this has probably
come to the four more recently is
climate change so what do I mean by the
three things well budgetary pressures
you've heard all about those we cannot
keep
subsidizing car parking we just hav the
funds to do it and I use the word
subsidy because that's what it
is where I am wrong is saying that it's
babber that's subsidizing car parking it
isn't it's the residents of babber that
are subsidizing car parking those people
that don't have a car those people that
don't use the car Parks those people in
the East that are having to pay for car
parking elsewhere they are subsidizing
the car parking in Hadley laven and
srey we have a policy where
discretionary items I things that you
don't have to have but you can choose to
use should be paid for by the user and
car parking is the one that's not why
the people in the East don't ask people
in Sudbury to pay for their Brown bins
so why should the reverse happen on car
parking if you have use a service you
pay for it
the Strategic review were was completed
the end of last year uh very in-depth
review there were a lot of
recommendations that came from it a
number of issues that came from it and
in fact car parking charges came
out on the side of we should be charging
for
them the one that I think needs to come
in is the climate change we're on what
is it storm seven Storm 8 of the season
so far we've seen lots of
flooding and I know this people will say
well introducing car parking charges
isn't going to make a blind bit of
difference to climate change but we have
to do things that we can do we have
targets for zero emissions we have
targets for
biodiversity traffic emissions from cars
and vehicles is one of the key things
that affects that and that's one thing
that we can do and we do know that subb
is does suffer from congestion It
suffers from people driving from one car
park to
another it does suffer from uh bad air
quality so we should be looking at do
introducing measures which cut down the
number of
unnecessary car
Journeys
and by having car parking charges or
increasing car parking charges or
changing the structure means that we can
look at other things we can do things
that are positive we can improve the
quality of the car Parks improve the
quality of the signage we can make the
spaces slightly bigger we can have uh
solar panels on some of the car Parks we
can have increased electric vehicle
charging we could introduce something
which a lot of people would I think
benefit from which are things like
Hopper
buses uh so buses that go just travel
around the town picking up people and
maybe there free to travel on we can't
afford those kind of things at the
moment we need to look at how we improve
access to the towns from The Villages it
may be once a week There's a bus route
that goes from the villages we can't
afford those at the moment either nor
can the county so they get cut these are
the things that increasing the revenue
from car parking will allow us to do
it's positive things that we need to
look
at
I really haven't got anything else to
say I think on that I think it's down to
you guys now to talk
about the issue of car parking but I
hope you look at it as a district in the
round it's not just an issue for the
people in the towns thank
you thank you Council
Bus the paper you have in front of you
is for noting we know that but it is
about what was agreed at cabinet most of
it is about what was agreed at cabinet
last
week so I'm going to open the floor for
counselors to ask questions on it but I
I'd just like to remind members that
overview and
scrutiny is here to be
impartial and a political if we can do
that okay thank you Katherine Council
grandon you want to ask the first
question yes
um thank you I it's mostly in response
to what councelor Busby
just sorry just
said um I mean I I my family and many of
the people I know don't use the legal
centers don't use many of the community
activities uh that we provide and so on
don't use our social
housing this is the way communities work
um you know we we pay for the greater
good of the whole community and the
greater good in in Hadley for example is
to keep a vibrant High Street and
vibrant businesses because without for
Hadley as an example but obviously
there's Sudbury and uh Lam with similar
situation
um without a vibrant High Street those
empty shops that because we forget they
are small individual shops that a small
change can make the difference between
viable or not this is for questions can
you get the question you would like to
ask so
um in that case I'll move on to the
climate change your climate change
comments it's really got nothing to do
with climate change because um in in our
areas we haven't got
Alternatives if we lived in London or
Manchester for example we'd have the
underground we've have very frequent
buses
and we'd have
alternative um councelor grandon but we
please you can you ask question
alternative transport are we going to be
providing that is going to be worth
people using when they come from other
parts of our
County well I
think it gives us an opportunity to
consider things as I said the The
Shopper bus the ho Hopper the ones that
we like to have outside here that takes
you into the Town Center or I don't know
whether they still do it but they used
to when I was a Cy canor way way back
and I appreciate that Hadley is
different to Su and it is different to
leam and they each have their own
individual requirements and demands and
problems but I could see that a shop at
bus would be very handy in Hadley you
know people probably drive I can
understand that people would drive to a
car park in Hadley because because let's
face it whichever way you go out of
Hadley it's almost guaranteed that
you've got to go up a steep hill well if
you've been shopping in town you don't
want to carry stuff up the Steep Hill
therefore you drive
in and it's those kind of Journeys there
might only be a mile but might be less
than that that really aren't efficient
in terms of climate
change I would agree that there would be
some short distances but this would not
work like I'm informing you it will not
work I have been doing a lot of um um uh
surveying of users of the car park I my
colleagues over the last few weeks and I
can assure you that will not
work councelor
Jameson thank you chair um okay I'm
totally um
totally um understand the points
council's made but in relation to other
options with the hull 1.8 million P hle
we've just seen in our budget even if we
introduce parking charges even unless it
was
a significant level how are we going to
afford Hopper buses and things like
that yeah I take your point Cy Jameson
um we we need to work out the the level
of
um tariffs that to
put in place in the relevant locations
and work out what we can expect to get
in terms of income over the next few
years
um but it's only one measure of several
that we're going to have to do and and
uh the chief executive talked about
different ways of working different ways
of doing things all of this together
will um the idea is will a um get rid of
our budget deficits over the over the E
term but also put us in a better place
to start doing some of these other
things that Council Busby has has
highlighted as as um both necessary and
desirable in terms of alternatives to
car travel we do want to um that the
whole point behind this yes I I I'll
fully admit is is revenue generation uh
income generation we have to we have to
do that but also changing Behavior we do
want to change people's behavior simply
because there are unnecessary car
journey is taking place um uh we we know
as Council Busby has said that people
are driving from one car park to another
they get a three-hour free period in one
car park they'll drive to another for
another three-hour fre period we want to
change these behaviors um we want to
reduce the amount of traffic going
through the center of subury
particularly because it's it's um it is
very congested a lot of the time um so
it's it's there it's one of many
measures um and we want
to have we we have aspirations to do
more than just use the income to to
balance the
budget
Mark yeah sorry just to add add one
point in there to u to council W there
um in terms of the we might I think I
think it's right that we're aspirational
and that we should be looking to replace
the Lost transport that's not there but
there's a stepping stone to go there and
we need money to come into the system to
actually help with that and there might
be that we can provide um grants seed
funding to community transport options
that help to bridge that Gap we know
that there are some operators out there
already and it might be that with
smaller sums of money we can actually
make those type schemes more viable um
where there's an element of um voluntary
resource that goes into those schemes as
well and there are some smaller um
smaller improvements we can also make
around um bik bicycles ebikes different
charges for that different um ability
people to able to securely drop those um
leave their bikes um in town and it it
steps in the right direction but when
we've when the system's running at such
a deficit and the overall systems
running a a big potential
deficit we we don't actually stand a
chance of getting in that
direction councelor Wyman please thank
you chair um just a quick observation to
start with I mean we're in a situation
here where we are looking and supporting
the conversation that goes back to
cabinet and ultimately to council um
interesting points raised by my
colleagues um on OB scrutiny counselor
grandon um
what economic impact has been evidenced
by either Hadley or sbur Town Council in
relation to what the financial downside
might be for their High Street that's
question one the second question relates
to the number of councils and I take
into point now say mid suffk west suffk
east suffer Kips bur Council how many of
those councils don't charge for their
car
parking on on the first one um I don't
believe that the town councils in in
either sub or hadly either of them have
have done any proper assessment on a
potential uh economic impact um evidence
around the country is anecdotal on this
there there's no there have been no
really detailed surveys all we can go by
is is what we see in other towns not
just in suff but elsewhere the vast
majority of small Market towns have car
parking charges of one form or another
you compare for instance just locally
compare subri with Stow Market the the
looking at vacancy rates the average
vacancy rate uh for the UK High Street
vacancy rate is 11.2% these are October
2023 numbers
the average vacancy rate for the east of
England is 12.5% which is quite High um
for sodbury it's 7.8% Stone Market is
7.3% slightly less than subre Stow
Market has parking charges yeah that is
one example where it clearly has no
impact but then we look elsewhere in in
suffk uh you you go around the county
and pretty much everywhere there are
charges of one form or another whether
it's large towns like obviously low St
or bar Evans or whether you go to the
smaller towns like halsworth sax mandum
places like that they've all got car
parking charges of one form or another I
think
um my recollection I did do um
investigation of this not so long ago I
know that hellsworth I think or is it
sax m one or the other there's only one
car park in one of those towns where you
where parking is free and that's the one
that car Parks run by the Town Council
those car parks that run by East suffer
Council carry a
charge those towns uh have not been
impacted you can hardly say that
Woodbridge is not thriving South wal is
not thriving halsworth that's doing fine
it's a very small town but it's doing
fine beckles that's doing very well as
well that's about the same size as sub
maybe a bit bigger so it we don't see
this this this fear materializing in
practice it just isn't there it is
purely a fear and the reality is
fundamentally different people will
still drive into the towns um from the
countryside from the neighboring
villages to shop locally it all depends
on the offer sub's got a great offer
lots of individual shops there water
stones have just opened up there Hadley
you've got the Adam store you got a
great butchers you got a great
delicatess people will still go for
those uh drive in for those even if they
have to pay a quid to park so the the
economic impact argument uh quite
honestly is is fundamentally flawed
there is no evidence for
it sorry just to continue that in fact
there's as much evidence anecdotal or
otherwise show that actually you
increase footfall by retaking traffic
out of the Town centers by increasing
the amount of pedestrianization Etc
people respond positively if traffic is
removed it makes them feel comfortable
it makes them feel as though they in a
place they want to be they will spend
longer there they will be more relaxed
they will spend more money it's not a
case of rushing in grabbing what you
want and rushing out again in that's not
the kind of person that we or customer
that we
want and look times have
changed the high streets aren't the high
streets of old we talked about retail
Parks we talked about online
shopping people shop in different ways
and we have to get used to that we have
to make the high streets more of an
attraction and possibly we could do that
if we have some funds to enable us to do
that and I see that particularly in
Hadley
there's a great opportunity in Hadley
to offer other things perhaps on the
High Street but we can't do it without
the funds to do
it followup question chair if I may to
on that that point
um so
evidentially there is no there's nothing
that we are aware of that would give
that level of financial impact to the
High Street and that's sort of more of a
yes or no you Council award and the
second point I'd just like to raise was
I I um I sat through cabinet a week or
so ago and councelor clover raised a
point in relation to a deot survey and I
I just remember the points he raised
which I thought was quite quite
interesting which was the two primary
points that was in the D report were
convenience and accessibility so are we
do you think we're sort of confusing
cost with convenience and
accessibility on your first point yes I
agree there's there's no evidence um to
to show that there is an economic impact
in terms of cost versus convenience and
accessibility well
yeah take Hadley for an example um it is
easy to get to the town the car pars are
conveniently located um The High Street
is very accessible and um
a modest cost is not going to have any
impact on that convenience and
accessibility thank you
Council thank you chair um following on
from Council Grandin and Jameson's
points about sustain sustainable forms
of Transport shifting to a different
transport wouldn't it be better to have
those Alternatives in place before you
start implementing charges
so that people can so people have got
something to use what happens to the
people who fall in the gap between the
charges disappearing if they do and the
transport being there um and secondly if
we need to start charging to make up the
shortfall is there any is there going to
be any ring fenced money from the
charges for these forms of transport
uh the first point
um look we're not experts in srey Hadley
laven pin whatever which is why that
we've started this consultation which is
why we want to go and talk to the town
councils and the parish councils that
are affected and come up with some ideas
as to how they would like to drive their
town or their Parish forward they may
have have some great ideas that we've
not thought
of they've not had the funds to do it in
the past perhaps but maybe we can offer
that so this is not us telling them this
is what's going to happen to you we want
to go out and them to say what we'd like
to see is we'd like to see two Market
days or would' like to see the High
Street closed or would' like to see
these activities come in or would' like
to see um transport free transport for
old age pensioners on a Wednesday or or
what whatever you know these are things
that we need to consult with the
parishes and towns for um whether we can
do it in advance of reducing or taking
away the free car parking I don't know
it's it's got to be financed and you
you've heard we don't have funds readily
available to invest unfortunately in
these kind of projects I wish we did
then yes we would could do that in
advance no um we we don't have the
funding available to to do things in
advance unfortunately um in terms of
ring fencing well that that's a
conversation we will have to have as
part of that um uh look at our
medium-term financial uh situation and
and um uh how we can budget for
everything we want to do the things we
have to do plus our aspirational stuff
uh going forward um in an Ideal World we
probably would want to ring fence but um
I can't make that promise now um it
would be something I'd want to strive to
do but we'll have to to to work out the
detail of this going
forward thank you I'm going to ask my
question next um I want to refer to the
paper that we have in front of
us um this was agreed at cabinet the
last cabinet meeting and this is um
about engaging with the public that's
not a why it's not a referendum we
understand that but there's some
engagement with the um can I ask the
director of operations to answer the
question is that right Council
Busby Mark could you explain to us what
you have been because you've obviously
thought about I mean you're proposing
this
engagement could you explain to the
committee how that is going to happen
thank
you um yes yes Council chair um we we're
going to work um mostly with our
strategic policy team which we've
actually started to do we'll design an
engagement um questionnaire in piece
where there will be a few questions on
that plus we'll be gathering um
everybody's views on the um parking
there where the main towns are concerned
are impacted by the parking we've
already started engaging with Sudbury
and Hadley and Lavenham and um and
chelston I've been and met the Clarks in
all of those towns and we've started to
attend um Town Council meetings take
board direct engagement ahead of this
formal engagement piece coming out as
well we also this um the engagement
questions will also be sent out to all
um District councilors all town and
Parish councils all recognized um groups
that we have as well we've recently
complet that the Strategic policy team
have recently completed some engagement
for the corporate plan so they have an
idea of the groups they've been um
speaking to for that as well so we will
then take themes from that engagement um
four and advantages disadvantages
concerns and they'll be represented in
the proposal I think one point I'd like
to draw members attention to in in the
report I've prepared is the advantages
and disadvantages table that is pulled
from the strategy from an officer
perspective um we're not saying that
there aren't some disadvantages to doing
this as well as some advantages to doing
this and that is the that is the balance
really to be honest and we will we are
seeking to engage with Council to
minimize the disadvantages and to
engineer out the disadvantages as much
as practically possible but I can't hand
on heart as the lead directors say that
there won't be a car that's displaced
from a car park if we go ahead with car
park charging that then chooses to park
somewhere where they shouldn't do
because the restrictions allow them to
do that but we will walk the towns as
we've been doing as councilor grandon
knows last week and and we will look and
seek to um to to reduce that as much as
possible when do you think that will go
out to Parish
councils I'm hopeful that we're working
hard to try and get it out before the
end of this week but worst case it will
be very early next week and we're trying
to give as close as we can to six weeks
as a decent time frame to turn um that
around obviously the the main council's
concerned
have made us aware very quickly of their
views on on it as
well thank you Mark
thank you madam chairman um first of all
I would like to agree that um Mark mem
has been doing a very good job of um
communicating with members he's walked
the Hadley car parks with me we've been
able to explain the problems and so on
so he is listening I will agree with
that I've a couple of things I would
like to say the first
thing yeah the first question is my
concern and and this is to um councelor
Busby really um is the
Democratic aspect of um taking the
2021 cabinet decision and carrying it
over to this period um when um um it's a
completely different cabinet now with a
different
political um Outlook different
individuals the whole Council has
changed and so you have different views
the current cabinet have not had the
opportunity to make um the decision
you're using the 2021 decision to
um they haven't been given
The Voice themselves and the council
hasn't been given the voice because it's
a new Council since last year so it
seems to me
undemocratic I know it's
allowed but it seems
undemocratic um to take that decision to
make your future decisions on this
matter on councelor grandon can I just
ask what your question is yes yeah how
can how can you consider that this is
democratic why have you taken that
decision and not given the
opportunity to um the new counselors to
make the decision we aren't and we are
giving the new cabinet the opportunity
to make those decisions but I mean the
chief exe my junior
might that before the the new cabinet
made a decision just over a week before
last
nothing to do with2 it's the 2021
decision no it wasn't it's a brand new
decision that's what you said no I
didn't I'll pass Chief thank you thank
you so yes just to help and in the
absence of the monitoring officer I
thought I'd jump in just to to explain
so you are absolutely correct Katherine
gron councelor grandon sorry if we were
simply implementing uh the decision made
previously then my personal view would
be that that would be undemocratic and
that is exactly what the cabinet is not
doing uh so that is uh history if you
like for babber quite clearly what the
cabinet is doing now is going is
starting from scratch because if it
weren't starting from scratch it simply
would have implemented it without any
further cabinet discussion without
bringing it to scrutiny without any
opportunity of repetition which
obviously will come to full Council that
bring it back to scrutiny again and
ultimately a cabinet decision in
proposed for March so it would have been
possible for cabinet simply to say this
is a decision that was made in the past
implement it in Al behind closed doors
without any discussion they haven't done
that for all the reasons you've just
outlined what they've said is no that
would be undemocratic that is a decision
made by the previous cabinet by the
previous administration outside the
current term of office and therefore we
are starting from
scratch so the decision has not been
made to charge correct thank you I
haven't heard that
before any DEC so I'll just clarify so
you already charge within your C box
yeah and I know what was I don't know
what you meant but just for clarity for
anyone's anyone watching so you're
already charged for your car Parks the
decision whether to charge uh for the
portion that is currently free yeah has
not been made otherwise there'd be no
point in carrying out the consultation
that Mark M's just outlined and any
decision will only be made after it's
come through back back through this
scrutiny committee and then on to
Cabinet in March so any decision at the
moment is assumed to be made around
about March thank you very much ke
executive because that's the first time
I've heard this thank
you what can I say that
we when you say it's un undemocratic
we're going through an awful lot of work
and effort to make sure that we get this
right it's not just about whether it's a
pound or 150 or whether it's free for
the whatever there's a whole host of
other things that are affected by this
and we are spending a lot of time effort
and money to make sure that we do get it
right this time or as right as we can
get it so I think we can making it as
Democratic as we possibly
can is there a question yes um so what I
had um just heard from the CU
executive is that the decision had not
been made to
charge um so I had
um and that was the first I had
understood that to be the case so can I
ask you um councilor Busby your um you
seem to be saying the the discussion and
the consultation is on how we are going
to charge not whether we are going to
charge could you tell me whether that's
right because that doesn't seem to be
um what we should be if the decision
hasn't been made yet to charge is the
consultation going to be on how we are
going to charge or whether we are going
to
charge it's kind of both really
um it's costing us £400,000 a year at
the
moment well the question is whether
we're going to charge or how we're going
to charge and that is not been decided
yet because that's why we're out for
consultation it may be that in one area
we decide that there's a certain way of
charging and in a different town there's
another way of charging or it might vary
by car park it might vary by day and
time it might not happen at all in some
areas we might have a free period I
don't know this is why we talk want to
talk to the towns to find out what is
important but if we if the towns come
forward with a a blanket we don't want
to any car parking charges increasing in
car parking charges and somebody's going
to have to come forward and tell us how
we're going to find an additional £4 or
500,000 to fix the hole in the budget
it's very easy to ask a question do you
agree with free car parking 99.9% of the
population will say yes if you say well
would you be prepared to give up and
close all your leisure centers to enable
that to happen I bet the percentage
would come down quite a
bit and if we off if we had to reduce
other services to enable us to keep keep
subsidizing car parking
again the percentage would come down but
we we haven't people haven't been asking
those questions it's a loaded question
do you want free car parking well yeah
of course we do but not at the expense
of everything else that we
fund you can't get free car parking for
nothing
counselor
thank you U you just mentioned the
Leisure centers now the Leisure centers
particularly the one in sub both have
car parks and the one in subury is the
main Town one of the main Town Car Parks
now any charges will have a knock on
effect on people members of the gyms um
of the Leisure
centers um and well potentially
depending on what we charge could double
or more than double a monthly fee for a
gym if they have to pay I mean is that
being considered in the consultation is
that going to be because obviously Sly
you could perhaps divide up by not
charging for that cup it's out of town a
bit but SRE you can't really it's right
in the
center yeah um yes yes councel there are
a range of challenges but yeah C
certainly um where leure centers are
concerned or where shops are concerned
where we lease their car park um then we
already work Arrangements um in the same
parking team in mids suffk where we
refund those um parking charges back to
the customer effectively so um yes that
that has been considered we can go
further than that so if there's a um I'm
aware in sbre and the king fisher leges
into car park for instance there's a
health screening um trailer that parks
there as well for for the NHS we can
give out mobile tablets and um to NHS
staff in that trailer and allow them to
enter carpart ations of their patients
that are accessing that service so that
they wouldn't get charged for the car
parking while they're accessing that
service um and that's yeah certainly a
good good example of something that we
you know we'll be factoring in at this
next stage as we do due diligence and
and develop a proposal um and we're also
obviously going a lot further than that
working with we'd expect to be
Consulting and working with GP practices
where they manage their own car parks
and Village Halls where they're U
managing their car parks and we do have
options to either incorporate those car
Parks into the parking order and then
enforce and allow them to issue out
virtual permits or um we can put them in
touch with enforcement as well um as is
the case for a number of retailers who
already enforced their own car parks and
um and do that successfully none of the
challenges we're facing are unique to to
us but we need to make sure we get the
potential Solutions you know right to to
really minimize the
disadvantages thank
you um you in the report it talks about
benchmarking on page four and five and
Council award mentioned a couple of
towns of a similar size beckles and
Woodbridge but there are other towns in
the region that don't charge for car
parking um I've got a list here but it
includes uh dis Windam
sofam um elely have have we looked at
those places and seeing their reasons
for not not charging and the way way
they go about why why they choose not to
charge yes we have we have looked at
some of those um places and we would
look at um look at those places part of
the review a number of those CH a number
of those um towns as as you're right
they may may have Arrangements where
they don't charge for the first hour and
then they charge and some towns don't
charge at all I think you find where
they don't charge at all that tends to
be a correlation with the Town Council
choosing to contribute towards the
district council and um that is
something that we've said is something
that we're open to to looking at as well
um and that's why we really want to um
to engage to be honest and also some of
the some of those towns that you
mentioned there are going through a
process at the moment of reviewing their
current arrangements as you as you'll be
aware of as well and um whilst we're
looking at the current picture it's also
with one eye on the future picture in
terms of what's what's happening but I
can only really State the comments we've
made in the report really about we're
looking to bring in a mod a modest um
tariff scheme as part of our proposal
and we don't want to set ourselves into
competition we we do we do realize that
um we've got a number of local
authorities around us that you know
charge quite quite highly to be honest
um which could be deemed as being compet
competition
really thank you um has it have you
looked
into um charges being introduced with
some sort of resident permit
system um yeah implementing implementing
resident permit zones is um an option
it's something that we need cooperation
from colleagues um at the County Council
um to to put in put in place um um in
Resident parking zones and yes that is
something that we might look at if the
demand is there um as a potential
solution to solve um parking that might
be displaced or nuisance parking or or
problems we've got at the moment the
County Council tends to um want to
consider a wide area and quite a large
Zone when it does this and there is
quite a high cost to those sort of type
schemes one would think they'd be a lot
cheaper than they actually are but we're
just putting stuff in on on Street the
surveys Etc that goes with it can be
quite expensive the other thing and
we've suffk have tended not to have many
of these schemes delivered across the
county at the moment there's one in New
Market that's been going through for a
long while now um trying to progress and
residents some residents tend to like
the idea of a scheme but don't like the
idea of having to pay for the permit and
then the restrictions that come with the
permits in the Resident scheme um but
yeah it's the we realize that on stream
is a challenge as well and by trying to
get on street right that would help and
we know for instance in um
sbur know the area councelor that um
that there are on Street challenges and
issues in there as well and if we could
if we can improve on Street enforcement
and it is harder to for um colleagues in
the enforcement teams in um in West
suffk and ipsid to enforce on our behalf
to enforce where the parking is free
whether a charges it tends to improve
the quality of the the enforcement
actually there as well which would help
to improve some on Street
issues if if I may chair could you tell
us a bit more how the zones this the
Zone thing
works New Market um I would not not
specifically about New Market but I know
residents parking zones you tend to look
at an area um look at the current
restrictions look at where there are
problems you go through an informal and
then a formal interview informal and
formal survey process you set s success
criteria in the surveys um in order to
move it onto the next stage yeah and
that can involve a series of um lines
signs physical restrictions or um um put
in place on on the streets to control
parking with permits being issued out in
a Zone um using the my permit system or
or manually to issue the permits out
really the cost for the permits would be
connected to the level of enforcement
required so that might not be something
that we're entirely under under our
control enforcement authorities play a
part for that as well so it's it's it's
a parking system and we don't we don't
operate all of all of
it I think I think residents sorry just
residents parking I think it seemed like
a golden ticket to solve a problem and
it tends not to be I mean one of the
reasons is that you might find that
there's a a cold where there's 50 houses
and you think well there's 50 cars there
might only be 20 spaces for people to
park so the 50 people apply for a
residence per there's no guarantee that
they're going to get a space and then
there's the people that are out all day
they don't care where people whether
people come and park in their close
during the day but there are people that
are in all day and don't want people
parking but then they get the visitors
so where if you it's not easy to design
a resident parking system that suits all
of the residents it isn't it's very
difficult I've been involved in one in
Pinewood and it was a nightmare the
thing that I've going back to something
else given that this is such an
important topic for Sudbury and Hadley
particularly
Sudbury I'm really surprised that the
Town Council don't come up with a
solution to make sure that they can keep
it if it's that if it's the most
important thing for the town if it's the
number one thing that keeps the town
alive why isn't the Town Council saying
we'll take on that responsibility it's
our town we want to make it the best
we'll take on that responsibility rather
than just abdicate it to a district
council where everybody pays that's the
biggest
surprise councelor grandon you had
another question thank you um in
Hadley um we've been carrying out a
survey of every uh retail and
Hospitality business in the High Street
and just off the High Street and we've
also been surveying users of the car
Parks one of the things that has come up
is we've also surveyed the market
Traders they're particularly worried and
would um would like um free parking to
continue on Friday mornings and Saturday
mornings are the most busy times in
Hadley that so that's one question my
second question is um
currently um on from midday on
Saturday till I can't remember what time
in the morning on Monday there are no
parking restrictions at all you don't
even need a free
ticket um would that continue in
Hadley so that's two questions
there um yes sorry sorry just just just
to answer that there um
that's that's something we'll want to
discuss as part of the engagement I
think any changes that are sort of
suggested and what you're referring to I
think there is sort of concessions for
markets for end of certain day where you
know it might be cheaper after a certain
time or three of charge after a certain
time we'll look at as part of any
proposal and choose what to bring
forward at this stage we've got we
haven't done the piece of work to model
the costs and model the cost going
forward we've just stated what the uh
budget costs are effectively at the
moment they they won't necessarily be
the actual costs going forward and we
need to complete the income modeling as
well and we need to factor in what we're
going to need to achieve our car parking
strategy and what we need to do to
invest in the car park so there's quite
a bit of work still that needs to be
done there and yeah we'll take on board
any findings and any evidence from I
know I know um councel and other
District councilors are carrying out
some survey work and and um separately
to that we're also engaging with had
lead Town Council and we we we're doing
that and um looking at their feedback
that they're giving giving us as well um
so yeah and all of that will be bought
into the proposal and but we do need to
have a mind on what's fair and La we
haven't mentioned laam too much as yet
I'm conscious of as well and we're
engaging with laam Town Council have
already given us their outline views on
this as well um could I thank you um are
you aware that
every um business that we have
surveyed has said and I will say more of
this when we come to debate but every
business feels that um the losing free
parking three hours free parking will
damage their business
um there most of those businesses are
local people who own the
businesses um and who work in them um um
and so we're damaging the local
economy with this um so and and are you
aware also that um a lot of the people
that
um that use the the facility the parking
facility are volunteers either
Volunteers in
the shops the charity shops or volunteer
in other
organizations within the town how are
you going to deal with people who
volunteer their time because then it'll
end up costing them to volunteer you
know we have lots in in the center of
the town we have places um like at the
anal Center where people work with um
the demential
organizations there's
um each
charity shop for example has 18
volunteers who all do thre hour stints
because it's worked around the three the
free parking that's why they do three
hours how are you going to deal with
volunteers I think I think his council
is aware at the moment um funding for
the voluntary sector is sort of under
pressure in general so um if there's
less funding in the system full stop
then the whole voluntary sector is going
to find their under pressure and um the
20 um 23 out 29 councils in the Eastern
region have no form of charging at all
so this is not a unique issue to Hadley
at all at all with this happening and um
we will look and consider whether
there's anything that um can be done but
of course whilst we're trying to solve
one problem in terms of removing a
deficit if at the same time um you we're
giving over concessions and subsidies
then it's reducing the ability to sort
of solve that problem and in terms of
evidence then yeah we will be as part of
the engagement process looking at um the
evidence that you're going to be
providing and the survey results and the
methodology behind that and um we'll be
happy to look and consider that yes
because while I was talking to the
manager of each who's explaining to me
about this his he's worried about losing
his
volunteers um one of the volunteers said
to me I give up my petrol money to come
and volunteer here to pay for parking we
do understand that's concerning
obviously there are there are the these
these shops have out these charity um
stores do have outlets in other towns
where they have to pay for parking as
well so they do operate extensively
across the across the area in in those
town sorry do I are you saying they will
have to pay for their parking I'm not
saying anything at the moment but I'm
just saying I'm getting an answer to the
question the the um towns other towns
where you have to pay for parking you
there are people still work in charity
shops in other towns so it's not a
unique problem to Hadley is all I'm
saying but we'll take on board any
evidence and and look at that as part of
the engagement and um and our proposals
thank you councelor
Smith thank you um you explained
about the possibility of a parking
permits for residential zones for on
street parking would it would there be
any POS possibility of parking permits
for residents B you know if you're a bab
resident you could park in a babber car
park for whatever it is 50 gr a
year
um that's one question secondly are you
proactively Consulting with the
supermarkets such as waos Morrison's Ali
and
sub that have car parks that are
currently free and will be impacted by
any any charges that may be brought
in so first question yeah we we
currently offer season tickets they're
heavily heavily subsidized um and you
know part of these proposals will be
bringing reviewing the the tffs on on
season tickets but they are available
and they're available um virtually
online as well um and yes we will we we
will make engagement with the
supermarkets a low say like the
previously answered questions that
they're not unique problems to Sudbury
um in terms of the supermarkets they
already have enforcement but clearly
clearly there would be some migration
from a free caring car parking option
into a twoh our free car parking
waitrose and and that may impact the
waitr store making their own commercial
choices about whether to change the
level of stay or the um the the
arrangements that they have in place on
their enforcement which we we can't do
thank you Mark uh councelor Jameson but
I'm going to make this the last
question considering this is a
information bulletin for noting I'll if
you ask the last question we will go
into debate thank you um in regards to
the
consultation um now obviously people
over in Pinewood um Peninsula they're
more likely to go more likely to go to
places like light switch even Felix to
Woodbridge than sbur or Hadley where
they probably have to pay for charges
anyway so think they're going to have
less interest in charge whether charging
sbur and Headley than perhaps someone in
Boxford or great wenfield so are you
going to wait the responses you get back
on or take into account where the
responses are coming from and their
potential
interest the the main part of the
engagement process is to um to solicit
detail that will help to design The
Proposal as of as opposed
to draw out a referendum based on the
number of number of um respondents yeah
because clearly a split of just District
a split of District councils of Parish
councils of different groups that could
come forward might not wait like that so
it's not our intention to be producing
bar graphs for this and for that saying
on this this is really about engaging
the pro um engag in engagement to inform
the proposals to engineer out the
disadvantages and we understand there's
you know a democratic process around
making the choice decision about any
proposal that's been brought forward and
as officers we've been asked to bring a
a a proposal forward and some options
have been discounted on the night of Jan
at that stage as well um and we'll bring
forward options in our
proposal thank you councilor Ward yeah
just just further to that residents in
the whole District whether they uh live
in Glenville in the west or srey or
Hadley or laam or wh over to shutle in
in the East all our residents are
Council taxpayers they all benefit from
the services we provide they all
therefore have an equal interest in this
decision because it affects our budget
so um we will be uh just as interested
in pinewood's responses as we are in
cornard
responses
thank thank you councilor Ward
commiss thank you chair um before I sort
of go into the debate element of of what
I'd like to say
I think I have a responsibility as a
committee Vice chair to support the
chair's initial comment in relation to
our independence and
impartiality um we act for the district
not for Hadley not for Sudbury and not
for laven that's that's really critical
point
um the debate centers essentially around
the economic vibrancy of of of of the
towns and I completely understand uh why
the town shopkeepers Etc would feel
threatened by this I mean who doesn't
like free car parking I love it every
time I go to handle it I think it's
marvelous Park up for three hours walk
away from the car it's great um but we
have to take some level of
responsibility I mean Council Busby
related the point concerning the
environment okay it's only a small
element of what we're talking about to
some extent but if we don't nudge the D
across it's never going to happen is it
free car parking is something that
everybody wants and not everybody gets
it I mean I I don't have my ward
uh my ward is Capal sub Maring my
residents live nearer to IP Swit than
they do anywhere within the towns we're
talking about so I'd like to think that
I have some level of objectivity about
how we should look at this
um we talked about free car parking we
need to also be really mindful of the of
the budget deficit this represents
nearly half a million pounds of budget
deficit and we cannot personally I can't
anyway sit on this committee and say at
any length we should continue with
without supporting uh cabinet and our
senior leadership team in
reviewing reviewing
the charging structure it would be
totally inappropriate of us not to
support that uh that expectation on
behalf of the cabinet and the council
thank you chair
okay thank you um yeah I do think back
in 2021 I think it was when we last did
this one of the big complaints is we
didn't engage with the towns councils so
I do think this paper demonstrating that
we're going out and actually engaging
with the um residents and the town
councils parish councils is a is a good
thing and it's a key that we're doing
this um in terms of whether we do
Implement charging or not as um cancel
Ward and councel buby said themselves
the you go to a town because of what the
town's got there I mean I would much
rather go to Berry than ipswitch because
Berry's a much nicer place in my eyes
than IP they both charge I don't think
you'll go to I don't think you go
somewhere just cu the parking's free you
go because the place is attractive the
place he got things you want to go to
see you and you spend we want to spend
time so ultimately I think if our towns
draw people in people won't care about
the charges as long as they not silly
charges
obviously um
so I think we by and by concentrating on
the charge and I think we are averting
away from the fact that our towns are
lovely towns and they can be key drawers
for
people and I think that's what we need
to emphasize as and it's good as I say
it's good that we're doing the pay the
consultation from the start this
time thank you Council
Jes
thank you um as I mentioned um we have
um so
far surveyed over 200
users of um the car parks in
Hadley and um yes there will be change
of behavior um as councilor bosby said
he he wants to encourage a change of
behavior but may not be the kind of
change that he would choose because a
lot of people said well they'll park on
the road then obviously there won't be
enough room for everyone to park on the
road but it'll cause chaos and it'll
cause upset for the residents because um
in the streets around um The High Street
it's mainly um people who don't have
off-road
parking um so I am concerned about
displacement um so and that is something
I've spoken to Mark mem
about and you know he is
listening um the other thing that has
been coming up in in the survey is that
people come from quite a distance to
come to Hadley because they do like it
um contrary to what um councelor bosby
said our town doesn't actually need much
changing we don't want it to change much
because it's lovely as it is we've got
lovely independent shops I a new shop
open called yarn works I thought well
that's not going to last very long I
thought who buys wo
nowadays this
survey has been an absolute eye opener
because huge numbers of people are
coming from chelsford Norwich Cambridge
ipswitch shoply
for this yarn shop apparently it's the
best yarn shop in in for miles around
and they do courses and things like that
so people come for a long time now
admittedly those people will pretty
prepared to
pay um because they're coming for a
specific purpose and they're coming from
a long way and they're probably coming
from somewhere where they would have to
pay anyway if they're coming that long
distance they're coming for but most of
the people who come on a regular
basis are not wanting to pay and they're
saying they're going to come to Hadley
less
often they will try and park on the
street they will come less frequently
they won't stay as long they won't be
staying for the coffee that we want them
to have this is I have the evidence of
this I have been interviewing hundreds
of people now and this is what they're
telling me um so you know I have the
evidence I have the evidence of the
shops that are really concerned they say
we can't afford to lose people because
we need we need you a few Shoppers
difference can make a difference to the
success or otherwise of their business
we have interviewed every shop in the
High Street and every Hospitality
business in the High Street
we have only about two empty shops at
the moment and we don't empty shops are
not going to give us the rates so we may
gain in
one uh way but we'll lose in another so
I'm you know it it is the
viability of places like hudley and
sodbury and
lenam it makes people want to live in
those places people choose to live in in
our towns and Villages because of the
vibrancy of the shopping Village and the
shopping um offer um if we ended up um
having um chain stores it wouldn't be
such an attractive place to be and we
wouldn't be attracting people who want
to live there people who want to visit
there so I have a concern about the
long-term success of our three places
that we're talking about today thank
you councelor
Smith thank you um I think I'd like to
go back to Alternative transport buses
cycle Lanes there's not enough of them
now it's a shame they weren't put in 10
years ago it's a missed opportunity they
we need to have them as soon as
possible so that people can people who
live
as Katherine says it's not the people
from far away who who come and will be
put off by parking charges it's the
people who live in the local area for if
it we're talking about Sudbury it's the
people who live in cornard or the local
Chilton Woods how are they going to that
the these people can't
cycle through sub there's no cycle Lanes
um they they will drive they'll be put
off um let's give them cycle Lanes then
perhaps they can come and they won't
clog up the town with their
cars um let's find a way to do that as
soon as
possible thank you chair can I come in
on on few few points that um Katherine's
made
particularly effectively what we're
doing is we're subsidizing the retail
element of Hadley and Sudbury is that
fair on the other businesses in Hadley
and Sudbury who made the decision that
babber residents were going to subsidize
a particular type of business rather
than what perhaps if I owned a hotel I'd
be saying what are you doing for me
you're not subsidizing me you're
subsidizing the war shop we've never
made a decision that we were going to
subsidize one particular type of
business that's just one point
interestingly you made the point that
the
um the market Traders were saying oh
definitely don't charge on a Friday and
a Saturday morning because that will
affect us interestingly I'd say it's the
reverse because people will go to Hadley
on a Friday and a Saturday because the
attraction is that much greater
therefore they'd be prepared to pay the
pound to do it you know also um a wise
person mentioned not long ago that if we
put the price of coffee up from
to3 would people stop going to
Hadley I suspect not they'd just say oh
okay I can understand the prices have
gone up and they'll just pay it we're
making a big fuss on one particular
aspect but there are many other things
that people seem to be prepared to
do of a similar
magnitude the length of stay again you
asked the question people say oh we
won't come so often and we won't stay as
long well if we said that it's a I don't
know a pound for a minute or a pound for
three hours why wouldn't you stay for as
long as three hours you wouldn't rush
out after two minutes would you you'd
stay you think oh I've got three hours
just the same as they have under free
parking so they'd still stay the three
hours and maybe they'd feel more obliged
to make best use of it because they've
paid for the
parking things have changed we've now
got electric
bikes how many people have electric
bikes that can now come into town with
those things like that now we're looking
at an uh an economy that's in
evolving we're not trying to solve a
problem or create an environment of 20
years ago we're trying to move it
forward to what the current situation is
and we have to change with the
times Council a last
com the arguments about the businesses
and and the the users of the car par
businesses in Stow Market in Woodbridge
they don't have these concerns the
people who live in Stow Market
Woodbridge and and wherever they still
go into those towns and
Shop they'll pay a pound or50 or
whatever yes they'll answer a survey in
a certain way but in practice they'll
behave fundamentally differently when
push comes to shove
so why I just do not understand why
Hadley and subb are unique amongst
Market towns not just in suffk or East
Anglia but in the whole country why are
they so different that the
behavior of people will be different
that the business concerns are any
different from anywhere else they're
just the same as other places and other
places still
Thrive honestly we we're talking about
will we going out and we'll be coming up
with a solution that um suits each of
those three locations but ultimately we
have to do this it's not a question of
uh yes or no it's a question of how we
do
it thank you I'm going to bring the
debate to a close actually the only
comment say to
members that um this paper is advising
us of what's Happening next as a
committee
once decisions have been made it will
come back to overview and scrutiny and I
think we've got to accept today this is
the paper in front of us that Mark and I
I need to congratulate mark because he
did this this very comprehensive paper
for us Mark which was really helpful but
we're at the start of this discussion so
I know how strongly everybody feels but
there will be other um places for you to
raise your concerns but I think today
I'm going to bring the debate to a close
and I want to thank you for your
contribution this report is for noting
only thank you can I just thank the
officers and uh both our counselors for
coming
today uh and I'm going to continue with
the agenda thank you so we get to agenda
item number nine uh the fourth coming B
BOS took 23
st07 forthcoming decisions list are
there any comments on
that any
members councelor
gr could I um I don't know if this is
relevant to this or maybe your your next
point but um you and I did speak at one
time of of um oh sorry this should
probably be under committee work topic
so I'll leave it till then yes sorry
sorry I'll I'll yes sorry the wrong
section my
apologies
um item 10 is about the overview and
scrutiny action tracker somebody that
was on Comm on overviewing scrutiny a
year ago I mean I think the tracker is a
is been a good addition to for the
committee to take note of what's
Happening have we got any comments on
the tracker as it's in your
agenda no there's still items actually
that have not been completed but that is
for a discussion
elsewhere so that's for noting Beth
okay um the work plan now that's what
you were talking about wasn't it so
that's item 11 BOS 23 stroke 09 bab
overview and scrutiny work plan did you
want to make a comment councelor
Grand yes sorry about that earlier um
you and I did mention or discuss um at
one stage possibly looking at the idea
of how the um changes to the telephone
system okay might affect um in
particular the elderly people in our
district um so for example you know the
whether it would affect their
um all that kind of thing I wondered if
that might be something we might want to
discuss about whether it's relevant to
do or
not can I just ask the members how they
I mean personally um I've had my phone
changed my
landline uh but we did have
um situation on
shotly uh where uh because of the
landline being disrupted that we had res
with pendant alarms and they were
actually at risk um and Council grundon
and I did discuss this would we be happy
to sort of get put that under review
would be because it's going to affect
everybody isn't
it I don't I don't know what it is but
well landlines been rerooted
into Jameson you're you're the whis kid
on you're the computer expert AR you
they're taking you're having your phone
rout retransferred from your socket on
the wall to your router which has
happened to me yeah and that does affect
these these pendant
alarms as far as I exp of being delayed
because of government concerns about
about dependent alarms and such like I
mean it's roll out all has been delayed
as far as
5 all right so maybe there's nothing to
discuss then well well some of us it's
happened to us I mean it affected my
phone I me quite honestly I won't tell
you what else because this is a public
meeting I won't tell you what else it
disrupted and there was no actually
discussion I won't say who the supplier
was but there was no discussion by the
supplier
so what were we hoping to get out of the
if we discuss it what we no I think
we're looking at I think what councelor
grund and I were discussing forget about
the rerooting of the but the the fact
that telephone lines in themselves so
they could be disrupted by anything you
know tractor sort of pulling them down
or something we we were concerned about
the vulnerability weren't we so are we
agreed to put it on the on the list for
review and then we have a look at
it if it we need to explore it don't we
whether it's a a problem or not I mean
it's not a it's not a solely Babor issue
obviously um
so yeah well we can put it on the list
it's a good idea councelor grandon and
then we'll review we can sit actually in
an informal meeting and discuss some of
these things I think I would like to see
a lot more discussion in our committee
together informally I I would you
welcome that yes I think I we all agreed
with that that may not include mid suffk
though it may be just relevant to
B anything else that
um yes um when we was um back in
whatever it was we were sorting out the
work
plan um we agreed to look at planning as
a whole including all aspects of
planning but we only ever seem to come
up with planning enforcement which is
important that's all that ever seems to
be talked about are we looking at other
areas of planning in the
future or it was back in July or August
whenever it was we did say enforcement
and other areas of planning now the
problem we've got today I don't know
really see us still on the call is she
would she be willing to give us elissia
is the one that yeah does
this just a minute yes chair not sure if
you can hear me not thank you thank you
Alysia nice to see you and hear you je
sorry I can't be there this afternoon um
yeah in terms of that item councelor
Jameson we will be hopefully looking a
bit more um at planning as a whole I do
appreciate that I have put that down a
work plans as just planning enforcement
um but it will take a bit of a wider
scope um we've not yet discussed at
chair's briefing it is coming up at the
next briefing which is next week so um
we'll have several meetings with uh
between myself the chairs and Tom Barker
and relevant officers to um get that
fleshed out so if you have specific
items that you want us to raise and talk
about in that briefing you're welcome to
let me know or let Council McLaren know
as your chair and we'll take those
forward okay does that answer your
question c yeah thanks Jameson thanks
alissia uh councelor grandon you had
another thank you item um I know this
may not be popular with everyone but we
also talked about the impact of working
from home and whether doing a sort of
comparison of before um covid and since
then and on you know I don't know
delivery phone answering however you
decide to scope it um and while you know
I understand it is a a tricky one to do
in in the way that we operate I think it
is something that we need to examine and
it might be a practical thing to do
because it may be that we can work may
not be needed but maybe that we can work
out better or different ways of working
if needed or it may be working
absolutely beautifully that's what maybe
we should we should be looking
at thank you chair um oh sorry yeah
sorry did you hear what councelor
grandon said yeah I did pick up what
councelor grandon said this was about
working working practices actually
wasn't
it yep that's absolutely fine um I think
we potentially discussed incorporating
that into the staff productivity topic
which is it that list at the bottom of a
work plan um I I'm assuming the arur is
still in the room I can't see I'm not
sure if AR would want to um pick up on
that at all um but from an officer
perspective I'm happy to incorporate
that appropriate but that I'll
respond thank you Alysa for that
hospital pass um yes more than happy
from a staffing perspective that we look
at it um but I what I would say is
against the context of everything we've
been talking about already I'm not sure
it's the right topic or the most
significant project or the most
important thing to be looking at should
we say um but I wouldn't want to dismiss
it entirely I think for me it would be
really useful if scrutiny had a
hypothesis that it wanted to test um
then that would be potentially more
helpful because the world has changed
the notion of homeworking I would say is
here to stay um I'd also try and help a
little bit just while I've got the floor
to point out that we don't have any
homew workers we have some people who
work from home occasionally but none of
them are classified as homew workers so
in reality what we have is a real mixed
economy of people working in the
district site visits and such like that
they have to do as part of their job
People based in the district where
they're going out and uh taking
advantage of things like Costa and other
other venues to be able to other
facilities are of course available um in
order to be able to hold oneto ones uh
and catch up with their teams using town
Parish halls for uh Team meetings and
such like obviously some staff come in
here and then some staff work from home
but it's not a one- siiz fits all it's a
real blend um some of which is driven by
what that member of Staff what suits
them from a work life balance but all of
which is driven by business need so they
can't do just what suits them they have
to do and customer services is a prime
example uh if a customer service uh
officer who is operating a front desk
clearly they can't work from home it
doesn't work does it so it's a real
blend yeah as I say I think if there's a
hypothesis that that counselors would
like to test more than happy to look at
it um but bluntly coming back to where
you started the conversation if he going
to save me money I'm happy to do it if
it's an exercise in analyzing what we
already do then I would say can we leave
it alone
please councelor
grandon
anecdotally um I get people saying to me
they can't contact counsel or they can't
contact the department thereafter and
that kind of thing and they oh it's
working from home isn't it it's because
they're working from home so maybe it
could be honed in
perhaps to something that answers that
kind of problem might that be an idea do
you think yeah absolutely if it's
focused on accessibility and Council
Council accessibility of services I
there's a s irony of course that if I'm
sat working at home I'm at my desk I'm
more likely to answer the phone than if
I'm in the office where I might have
gone up and wanded off yeah absolutely
so um but I'm more than happy to to look
at accessibility because clearly for
both authorities I think for me it needs
to link back equally to is it one of the
priorities that is emerging through the
corporate plan which obviously goes to
full council at the end of this month so
if it supports that then again that
gives extra weight to why would we be
looking at
it I'd be
happy as as long as alissia is taking
this issue don't
AC yeah I think I mean we've we've
raised a lot of different items um I do
firmly believe and of course our our
interests don't necessarily match with
midu quite rightly we're two separate
councils um but I think there is sorry
no no no but they're not interested no
no no this is this is a baba thing okay
isn't it well it's a difficult one so
yes I think msag is interested the
administration in accessibility um I've
challenge that a few times just so I
understand what that's about I think to
some degree that's about visibility
rather than accessibility or a
combination of the two so we've had
lengthy conversations with the
administration about The Stone Market
customer service point and and how best
to use that and is it in the right place
and and that goes beyond access to
service but perceived perceived access
to Service as well so the the mid of
councilors administration want officer
sorry want the public to feel as though
the council is accessible to them as
well as actually being accessible to
them they want both um but I do think
and I think that's where you were going
coun grandon is it would be quite tricky
uh for something like the call center to
split out uh and look solely at babber
and not at mids suffk so there there may
be elements where we can but I think in
the round it would be it would be tricky
to do so and probably slightly
counterproductive
Alysa you want to come
in yes that's all okay chair I just
wanted to pick up on the points that
councelor grandon is making in terms of
members of the public having access to
um our
services um it might be beneficial to
note that we do have an item coming up
to the next committee on this sort of
topic um about how members of the public
can access our services online through
the phone through face to face um Sam
Lake um who's corporate manager for
customer services is going to be
bringing that item to the next committee
so hopefully some of those issues will
be addressed then um if there's more
specific issues coming out of that item
which you want to carry forward we can
bring that to a future committee if
needed councilor grandon I'm going
to you're the last comment because I am
going to bring the meting to a close so
that the um Lissa was just saying the
how could could I then add to that the
sort of efficiency you know is it
working not not just they can do it this
way but is it working then or and is it
being done dealt with efficiently and
quickly or whatever that kind of thing
as well then not just the you can do it
this
way but is it is it working as it says
to to review how they engag with and
rating different service
areas rating cover it I don't know I
think depends I think actually councilor
grandon I think we review it as a babber
committee at a later date we can have an
an informal
meeting um sometimes by being join sort
of restricts doesn't it in what we
discuss I think I want to bring the
meeting to a close it's 5:00
and I think we've had a good chance to
discuss everything that is concerning us
um and so if with your agreement I am
going to close the meeting but Council
Grand and Alysa and Beth are taking the
note and we will revisit those things
that you've raised as a concern so can I
thank our monitoring officer
today and thank you to Tom who stayed
all the way through and for for henriet
and Mandy and especially Beth just want
to thank them for the support they've
given the committee and everything
that's gone on today so I'm now going to
close the meeting the next joint
overview and scrutiny committee will be
held on Monday the 19th of February at
9:30 a.m. thank you very
[Applause]
much